-Guys, I want to quickly
mention, later this week,
we're going to be kicking off
our newest Summer Reads
book club contest.
-Ooh.
-We do this every year.
It's a lot of fun.
I'm going to pick five books
that I'm thinking about --
thinking about reading.
[ Laughter ]
-Thinking.
-That's what makes this club
different than any other club.
-Other clubs --
-I'm considering reading these.
-Yeah. Other clubs,
people read the book.
You think about it.
-That's correct.
I'm thinking about possibly
reading these books.
Then I'm going to
have you guys vote
on which one we should all
read together.
I don't want to have to read
all five of them.
Then you got to go,
"Oh, yeah, that one's --"
No, we all vote together.
We win together.
We lose together.
[ Cheers ]
Maybe --
Can we do six books?
-Oh.
-Can we do six?
It has to be five?
-You want to do six?
-We can do six?
-Go nuts, man.
-We might do six.
-Half a doz.
-Half a dozen, man.
I don't know,
'cause there's one I'm, like,
kind of flip-flopping on.
-Really?
-I'm not sure.
-You're not sure. So, six?
Make it six, man.
It's your show.
[ Laughter ]
Live. Live life, man.
Live it up. Live it hard.
-I want to make sure
we have every --
I like different
types of things.
I like my --
-Comic books.
-No.
-Cookbooks.
-[ Chuckles ]
No, I like my mysteries.
I like --
-Ooh. Histories?
Ghost --
-Memoirs --
"Mem-wah."
-"Mem-wahz."
-I like -- I like my kind of
summer romance books.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
Spicy.
-Yeah.
So I might throw in, like,
a little summer romance.
I like a Y.A. book in there
every now and then.
-Oh, yeah, man.
-Keeps me feeling young, man.
-Yeah.
On top of the pile, man.
-Yeah, I read --
I read while I --
-You read while you jog.
Yeah, I love it.
I've seen you do it.
You have the thing, the little
thing with the holder.
-You saw me in Central Park?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I was doing that.
I had the contraption.
-You were fast, man.
-Had the book in front of me.
And I'm like,
"Why is everyone looking at me?
Leave me alone.
I'm just like you," you know?
Wednesday we're going to go down
the list of the books,
the finalists.
But that doesn't really
mean anything.
[ Laughter ]
Because that's
when the fun begins.
-Yeah, the fun begins
on "Wedns."
-We'll announce
the five to six books.
[ Laughter ]
-5 1/2, yeah.
-And then I'll tell you
what they're all about.
Then we'll decide on which
is going to be the winner.
And then, when will we
decide the winner?
By next week?
So you got like a week
and a half to figure it out.
This is like --
You're on my schedule, right?
You don't have to decide
right now.
-No, man, it's all good.
-Take your time.
Take the weekend.
Enjoy yourself.
Go, "You know what?
I was thinking about this,
but now I like this.
I'm telling you,
it's probably going to be
one of those rom-coms. Steamy.
-Ooh, steamy.
[ Audience oohs ]
-I don't even know
if I've ever read one.
-A rom-com book?
-No, one of those sex books.
[ Laughter ]
-Like with, like,
Fabio on the cover?
-No, like "50 Shades of Grey"
or whatever.
-Oh, "50 Shades of Grey," yeah.
-Yeah.
Yeah -- You like it?
It's a good book?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe like on a Kindle
or something.
-Yeah, yeah.
You don't want people --
-I don't want to be
holding the book.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-If it's dirty stuff
on my Kindle,
that's up to me, you know?
If you're holding the book,
like, you know --
-You're reading
a, like, giant, dirty --
-"101 Ways to Do It."
-Yeah, exactly.
Big picture book. Rude.
-Stay away from that dude
in the subway, yeah.
Wearing my jogger's hat.
-Yeah, "Kama Sutra," yeah.
Run as fast as you can.
-"101 Ways to Do It."
What the hell is he doing?
Yeah, get a life.
-"Trip to Bone Town"?
That's an awful book.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-That was a good --
That was a good book.
That was actually --
-That is a good book.
-That had a twist ending
I did not see coming.
-Yeah, very twisty.
[ Laughter ]